[Music]
foreign
what are the biggest predators in
Pandora yes On LAN in the sea and in the
air let's get to it
at number 15 we have the sting bat this
relatively small creature primarily
feeds on insects and small rodents but
in a swarm we'll attack larger
herbivores like the hexaped The Sting
bat has a wingspan of 3 meters or 10
feet wide but its length is around 1
meters or 3.3 feet
number 14 the Viper wolf these are
six-legged animals akin to wild dogs and
wolves on Earth inhabit and behavior the
Viper wolves are vicious and will attack
even larger animals in groups they
themselves are just around 1 meters or
3.3 feet tall
number 13 the sharp two lizards these
are animals that are found in rivers and
small ponds and lakes they are like
Komodo dragons but they have an ability
to spit out a venomous saliva from a
distance they are around 1.2 meters or 4
feet tall but could be around 2-3 meters
long
number 12 this length this is one of the
fastest land predators of bandura and
also the evolutionary precursor of the
Slinger it injects its prey with a
powerful neurotoxin venom before eating
it alive not much is known about its
size but we can estimate it to be around
2 meters or 6.5 feet tall
number 11 the Slinger these are one of
the oldest and most dangerous creatures
discovered on Pandora growing in size of
up to 2.4 meters in height or 8 feet
this land predator prefers a dense
rainforest habitat and its main food
source is the hexapeep
number 10 the thanatore xenobiologists
believe that this creature may be the
land apex predator on Pandora this
enormous 2.4 meters or 8 feet tall
powerful and ferocious animal is unique
in its ability to Lord over its
territory and strike fear into even the
largest and fierces of Pandora's land
animals
number 9 the navi these are the sentient
humanoid creatures of Pandora and they
live in small societies communities and
clans all over the planet they have a
lot of subspecies or Races they are also
carnivores and are Adept at hunting and
killing almost any creature alive their
height is around 3 meters or 10 feet
tall although some are bigger
number eight the great astrophy the
great astrophyte is a bipedal flightless
bird-like creature that looks similar to
a Terran emu or an ostrich or an extinct
Silas bird it has two long four limbs
with very long claws two hind Limbs and
two Wings which are used to display or
fight against each other or also for
hunting it is 5 meters or 16.5 feet tall
number 7 the ilu although peaceful and
domesticated by the metcaine clans of
the oceans the ilu still are carnivores
much like dolphins and killer whales
although they only eat fishes and small
aquatic creatures in Pandora these ilu
are normally around 7 meters or 23 feet
long
number six the forest Banshee these are
large dragon-like aerial predators that
are native to Pandora they are used by
the navi for hunting from the air and
also to travel larger distances
the forest bunches are a smaller
subspecies and half are seven meters or
23 feet wide wingspan
number five the mountain Banshee these
creatures have four limbs instead of the
regular six and the wings are shaped
like an insect these are the bigger
subspecies of banshees the mountain
bunches are the larger ones and are
reported to be bigger having a wingspan
of around 13.9 meters or almost 40 feet
wide
number four the skim Wing this is a
large Oceanic Predator that looks like a
cross between a crocodile and a flying
fish it is able to Glide and fly by
skimming over the Sea's surface at
speeds of up to 60 miles an hour or more
than 90 kilometers per hour even if it
is huge at 14.6 meters or 48 feet long
number three the great leonopteryx this
is by far one of the most feared
creature in Pandora also known as the
dog it is a flying behemoth with a
wingspan of over 25 to 30 meters or 80
to 100 feet wide and hunts all other
animals including the titano tears
Thanatos and Banshees
number two the akula this Marine
Predator has three Jaws that split
outwards in three ways when hunting it
is around 30 to 40 meters or 100 to 131
feet long and can swim at very fast
speeds the akula was the one seen in the
way of water hunting Jake's son until it
was killed by a Tolkien and number one
the nalutza this is the biggest predator
in Pandora and it is a sixth Guild
monster that dwells in the oceans and
may be seen springing out of the sea
sometimes it is a hyper carnivorous
animal that may grow to be around 40
meters or 131 feet long bigger than the
blue whale of Earth
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video on the 15 biggest predators in
Pandora do hit that like button for
support and subscribe but most of all
smash that Bell icon for regular updates
on new videos right here on this channel
till the next one take care fam